tja und jetzt sag ich guten ab nach
berlin zur jens trainer
bundesvorsitzende der jungen liberalen
und damit auch einer der frisch
gebackenen fdp neuen
bundestagsabgeordneten
schönen guten abend er hat sich den
glückwünschen können sie sich herr
trainer eigentlich erklärt warum sie
fast plötzlich so attraktiv sind für
junge wähler wir sind nicht platz auf
einmal attraktiv geworden für junge
wähler sondern schon lange haben wir da
hohe zuspruch werte und das hat
verschiedene gründe als erstes würde ich
anführen dass 75 prozent der jungen
menschen sich von den corona maßnahmen
vergessen geführt haben es gab keine
bafög reform nicht alle eingriffe waren
verhältnismäßig gerade meine generation
mit besonders unter sozialer isolation
laut studien und die fdp war der
ansprechpartner zeitgleich haben wir mit
zukunfts agenda aufgelegt und die
wichtigen themen auch angesprochen die
ein teil der jungen menschen auch sehr
wichtig sind beispielsweise demographie
also haben die gesetzliche aktien rente
vorgeschlagen digitalisierung und
dekarbonisierung und wir haben ganz
eigenen markenkern wir haben auf
freiheit statt bürokratie gesetzt auf
erwirtschaften stadt verteilen und auch
mehr freude als veranstalter bieten und
haben nicht mit taktischen argumenten
wahlkampf geführt sondern aus
inhaltlichen überzeugungen das kam alles
zusammen dann hat mir noch einen guten
spitzenkandidaten und so haben wir dann
sehr erfolgreich bei jung und
erstwählern abgewählt und das bild das
ist die jugend gab es vorher hatten sehr
häufig gesagt wurde die jugend ist
vaters der future das wahrheit schon
immer falsch und deswegen ist vielleicht
auch ein fall schranken gibt eine jugend
die sehr engagiert ist und die auch
nicht nur die fdp aber auch die grünen
gewählt hat also auch da gab es da muss
es dann ja große übereinstimmung geben
und von denen punkten die sie gerade
eben genannt haben zumindest dass die
beiden ersten unter anderem corolla oder
auch digitalisierung da können sie sich
doch die hände reichen ich glaube nicht
dass wir uns da komplett die hände
reichen können an allen themen was bei
der kampagnenführung und im wahlkampf
vielleicht ähnlich war olaf scholz
harten wahlkampf geführt weil sich als
die nachfolge von angela merkel
inszeniert hat die union wollte sowieso
am liebsten ein weiter so und sowohl
grüne als auch fdp haben für eine
modernisierung
gestritten zwar mit ganz
unterschiedlichen akzenten anderen
inhaltlichen überzeugung aber sie sind
beide nicht mit dem status quo zufrieden
und eine gemeinsamkeit und das teilt
glaube ich auch ein großer teil der
jungen generation und wie viele grüne
freunde haben sie
ich frage mich alle meine freunde nach
ihrer politischen färbung aber der ein
oder andere studiert philosophie da ist
auch der ein oder andere mit einer
grünen einstellung dabei die frage
natürlich sehr hängen wo sehen sie die
großen übereinstimmungen und
überschneidungen auch da sie jetzt die
basis für eine neue regierung legen
sollten im moment
ja das werden wir in den
koalitionsgesprächen aushandeln deswegen
halte ich auch den weg für richtig dass
wir als allererstes mit den grünen
gesprochen haben nämlich hat sich das
parteiensystem mit der bundestagswahl
neu sortiert es gibt nicht mehr die
kanzlerpartei die 35 40 prozent haben
die beine und zwei kleine parteien
sondern die kleinen sind an die großen
ran gerückt wir haben eine eine partei
oder eine von den beinen wird ja den
kanzler stellen mit knapp 25 prozent und
da gibt es jetzt vier mittelgroße
portalen und deswegen ist es auch
richtig dass fdp und grüne als erstes
miteinander sprechen damit diese
neujustierung sich auch widerspiegelt
jetzt die kanzler macher
das haben sie gesagt dass wir nicht mal
eine formulierung und irritation er hat
es so ausgedrückt er gesagt dass es
super dass wir miteinander sprechen
damit lassen wir uns auch nicht von olaf
scholz spalten haben sie denn angst auf
olaf scholz sie spalten würde also die
grünen und die gelben ich finde es auch
wie jamal stimme mir richtig dass wir
miteinander sprechen und zwar sehr
vertrauensvoll weil keiner wusste ja von
den treffen gestern abend aber man hat
die gleiche kommunikation angewandt und
ich finde dass im vergleich zu jamal k
sehr sehr erfrischend wo man quasi jeden
spiegelstrich aus den aus der presse
schon erfahren konnte den widerspruch
als erstes in der presse lesen konnte
und jetzt hat man als erstes gedrückt wo
sind die gemeinsamkeiten gibt es eine
vertrauens- ebene und ich finde das sehr
sehr frisch und weil so oder so wird die
fdp mit den grünen regieren weil rücken
möchte eigentlich keiner mehr aber jetzt
haben sie die sorge der dlc mehr hatte
dass es so ein spaltpilz kippte durch
olaf scholz oder haben sie gar nicht
ich weiß nicht ob urlaub scholz und mit
denen ist aber wir haben in den letzten
tagen schon ein paar spd angriffe auf
die fdp erlebt gekümmert hat zum
beispiel christian nicht nur einfach als
luftikus bezeichnet weiß nicht ob das so
eine nette umgangs artist in den
politischen diskurs der mann eigentlich
vielleicht der interesse hat auch eine
koalition zu bilden so wird es ja von
der spd auch eigentlich artikuliert die
grüne jugend möchte jetzt gerne von
ihrer parteispitze eine absage an eine
koalition mit der union also an jamaika
was sagt ihr dazu ja das wundert mich
wenig die grüne jugend steht links von
den von der grünen bundespartei
die wollten ja schon von vornherein auch
rot-rot-grün zum glück ist das
verhindert worden und es gibt keine
mehrheit für rot rot grün und die haben
vielleicht jetzt so ein bisschen die
vorstellung das ist jetzt ein rot grünes
bündnis gibt mit so ein bisschen gelben
schmiermittel dazwischen aber das teilt
die parteiführung nicht und deswegen
finde ich es richtig dass die fdp wir
sind eigenständig in die wahl
eingegangen auch jetzt weiter noch keine
koalition ausschließen und hat die
präferenzen ich habe die präferenz dass
sich unsere inhaltlichen überzeugungen
wider spiegeln lassen in den
koalitionsvertrag darum geht es nicht
wir wollen die modernisierungs agieren
da für das land das ist meine präferenz
und wir werden nach den gesprächen dann
gucken wo sich das am meisten umsetzen
das alter das kann auch offen sein nach
den sondierungen schauen sie dann weiter
wenn ich das richtig verstehe das ist
korrekt jetzt heißt es ja im
staatsverständnis da gibt es die größten
differenzen oder nicht die größte aber
es gibt große differenzen zwischen den
grünen und den liberalen also ein staat
der eben sehr für sorgen der ist er
jetzt vielleicht auch mehr zu schulden
tendiert um ebenso einer pflicht gerecht
zu werden und hingegen sidi sie haben ja
eben das auch bei ihrem markenkern am
anfang gesagt die eben mehr für das
entdeckt und für das ja selbst sorgen
die denken wohl denken sie dass sie in
das irgendwie überbrücken können oder wo
sehen sie denn da die brücke ja
selbstverständlich gibt es unterschiede
auch grundüberzeugungen sind eine
liberale partei wir wollen kein staat
der den einzelnen bemuttert oder
bevormundet sondern befähigt wir wollen
die modernisierung des bildungssystems
beispielsweise die verteidigung von
bürgerrechten und kämpfen für eine
offene gesellschaft die letzten drei
genannten würde man vielleicht auch bei
den grünen finden es gibt sowohl
gemeinsamkeiten als auch differenzen
aber das ist doch normal in einem
parteiensystem davon lebt doch unsere
demokratien dass nicht alle parteien
auch gleich gefärbt sind zum schluss wie
lange wird das dauern mit dem sanieren
so schnell wie möglich so langsam wie
nötig jens trainer herzlichen dank der
bundesvorsitzende der jungen liberalen
schöner abend nach berlin schönen abend